a barista poured a cup of coffee the
initial temperature of the coffee was 90
degrees celsius
at time t
increased as as time t increased the
temperature c of the coffee began to
decrease exponentially and approach room
temperature of 20 degrees celsius which
of the following
which of the following graphs could
model this relationship so we're
starting at 90 degrees celsius it looks
like all of the graphs start at 90
degrees celsius at t equals zero
and we are going to get we're going to
approach the room temperature of 20
degrees celsius so this first one does
degrees celsius as t increases
now this one
when t is
and when t is 70 i'm assuming this is in
minutes when t is 70 it looks like it
has the temperature going to
zero degrees celsius so that that cup of
coffee is going to start freezing so i
think i could rule out b also this looks
like a linear model not an exponential
one
c it does get us to this end state that
stays at 20 degrees but it doesn't look
like an exponential model looks like
it's linearly decreasing and then it
stops linearly decreasing after 50
minutes and then it just stays constant
at that temperature of 20 degrees so
even though it gets us to the right
place it does not look like an
exponential decay so i would rule choice
c out as well so a is looking good
d we are starting at 90. it does look
like an exponential an exponential
function we have exponential decay right
over here we and we are approaching
something but it's not the room
temperature of 20 degrees celsius we're
approaching 30 degrees celsius here so
i'd also rule out d
so a is looking good it's an exponential
it's decreasing exponentially starting
at 90 degrees celsius and it's
approaching the room temperature of 20
degrees celsius let's do another one of
these
so it says
let me scroll up a little bit
so it says after cl after the closing of
the mills the population of the town
starts decreasing exponentially
the graph below presents represents the
population p in thousands of the town t
years after the closing of the mill
all right so it looks like the
population starts at 40 000
it's decreasing exponentially it looks
like over time the population is
approaching 20 000 people
so what is the question here based on
the graph with the mill closed what does
the population of the town approach as
time increases well we just said it as
time increases it looks like it's coming
close to
it's approaching twenty thousand
it's approaching
twenty thousand it's already gotten
below twenty two thousand as far as you
know looks like by after twenty or
twenty two years we've already gotten
below twenty two 000 so we're definitely
below 30 or 40 000 but we're we haven't
gotten below 20 000 but we are
approaching it and we can even check our
answer if we like